[Musique]
on est malgré tout ça concerne des
populations qui sont à l'est de la
france consacre au cern trois
départements c'est-à-dire l'alsace de
département et la moselle ce sont des
gens qui est des hommes non seulement
les appalaches qui ont été incorporés de
force dans l'armée allemande
[Musique]
je termine existe déjà depuis 920 tu as
a concerné des citoyens allemands
puisque nous on était un excellent e de
droit alors qu'en 1942
on était un excès de fait et donc on
attendit que on a incorporé des français
d'original dans une armée ennemie
ce qui a été reconnu comme un crime de
guerre
[Musique]
c'est mamadou kassé la france est la
seule à l'horizon qui a inventé cet
acronyme malgré nous la première guerre
mondiale se sont développées les
associations d'anciens combattants en
cours d'une réunion un ancien combattant
qu'est et porter l'uniforme allemand l'a
fait remarquer il a dit nous on est
effectivement dans l'armée allemande
mais certains d'entre nous en porter
l'uniforme leur coeur défendant ses vers
israël se sont sentis obligés qu'ils
avaient leurs sentiments français mais
les circonstances en fait qu'ils ont dû
porter l'uniforme allemand il ya une
deuxième génération de mankind à 140 2
minutes et pas des civils
[Musique]
premier des malgré-nous départements en
france donc des territoires qui sont
situées à l'est de la france en fait à
la frontière de france et d'allemagne et
qui s'était ricouart été souvent l'enjeu
de deux guerres précédentes puisque l'on
en dise choses sont dix désagréments
l'allemagne les français ont perdu ici
on a été 48 oralement
donc aujourd'hui on en famille tous mes
grands parents sont nés allemand
puisqu'ils sont nés avant avant 1914 ils
deviennent français qu'après la 4d lui
les amoureux ont considéré que ces sept
autres de gars c'était une parenthèse 10
ans et pour certains français finalement
de ben voilà on aidé des allemands et
donc on n'a pas eu la même histoire que
le reste de la france
on a une histoire vraiment totalement
différente en est même pas en territoire
occupé en une aux territoires annexés
par la force puisque là c'est une mode
l'annexion de de fait en 2 via allemand
veut dire en vain pendant la première
annexion
les gens sont en plus facilité à
s'adapter déjà buté lui le temps et les
allemands la première annexion non en
fait une annexion qui n'a pas été brutal
alors que là en 1940 tout changer très
vite fédérer germanisation elle était
perdue de deux mois alors que les
premières élections ils ont 40 ans puis
il ya eu nazisme c'est à dire une
biologie totalitaires dans toute cette
histoire là n'est pas partagé par les
français ont fait pas partie de
l'histoire nationale en est une histoire
régionale
[Musique]
une forme d'incompréhension de part et
d'autre des territoires second avoir
porté nie formellement
on a des migrants mondial c'est pas très
flatteur et les alsaciens et les
mosellans il se bat toujours pour
expliquer que voilà les annonces et ont
été obligés dans l'est de leur maman ce
qui est vrai puisqu'il y avait ce qu'on
appelle lundi que la responsabilité du
clan et si on allait par de l'armement
en ne cherchait de quelqu'un de la
famille et on le déporter la possibilité
du choix était biaisé il y a eu
évidemment dans les familles des
discussions sur le fait est ce qu'on va
aller dans l'armement mais c'était pas
facile quoi ce que je fais pas les deux
larmes allemand ça voulait dire quand on
était d'accord pour prendre des risques
de sa famille il ya par exemple des
images mortuaire qui existe sur des
malgré nous oui j'ai écrit mort pour
avoir sauvé sa famille
[Musique]
les classes d'âge qui ont été mobilisés
alors c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose en alsace-moselle nasa ils ont
mobilisé de 1908 à 1928
ce qui veut dire que les plus jeunes il
avait à peine 16 ans et en moselle ça a
été les classes 1914 une eau saumâtre
adore aussi les sept ans les plus jeunes
qu'il ya un portique alors la
particularité c'est que eux aussi ceux
qui sont nés entre 1908 et 1h19 avait
déjà été de normer france il avait
combattu les allemands en 1940 ont été
faits prisonniers au 40 allemand doit
délibérer masculin également les autres
considéraient comme des membres de leur
communauté
sont rentrés chez eux et en 43 les a
mobilisés vont les alsaciens mosellans
il ya eu à peu près cent trente minutes
incorporé de force dans l'armée
allemande la plupart des malgré-nous en
t1 combattre à l'est essentiellement en
chine
[Musique]
heureux les mains très douce est
vraiment que des hommes puissent qu'on
avait des larmes allemande sauf que
depuis quelques temps en considérant qu'
il ya aussi des femmes qui ont été dans
des services auxiliaires de l'armée
notamment à la défense anti aérienne que
ces femmes là le c'était à peu près 15
la scène et mosellans alors des fois il
y en a qui ont été co aurait raté ch
arras d'inzaghi travaux à toi elles
n'ont pas continué à aller au clash dit
qu'il était une formation des trous
[Musique]
gates pour important pour les maliennes
ont ces discours du président sarkozy
il ya quelques années à colmar en alsace
qui a reconnu que les malgré nous et
être victime de la guerre il ya eu comme
une autorité nationale qui a qui a fait
rentrer les malgré nous dans une
catégorie de victimes de la guerre dans
un territoire français c'est une
exception quand je suis revenu en france
diane toujours une forme
d'incompréhension et en fait c'est les
surtout les alsaciens qui se battent
pour le respect que l'on comprenne
l'histoire des années s'est imaginé
[Musique]
on connait que des bénévoles
on s'est intéressé à l'histoire
nationale les gens qui ont produit cette
berlin qui malgré nous les plus jeunes
chez nous la 93 ans donc allez encore en
entraide basculer de la mémoire à
l'histoire et si elle n'est pas en finir
les écoles cette mémoire la sera pas
conservé et pourtant je trouve que c'est
intéressant de conserver cette histoire
régionale en et territoires annexés
c'est un particularisme local en france
trop les particularismes
on essaie de faire une histoire
nationale et donc on essaie d'éviter de
parler de ces de ces problèmes dans
locaux
[Musique]